[Music]
20 international chess professionals
converge in st. Louis for the 2017 fall
chess classic hello chess fans and
welcome to round three of the fall chess
classic things are just now heating up
and only one player still has a perfect
score first in group a Vladislav Kovalev
was able to win his game all the other
games were drawn this results in a sort
of logjam at the top in the group a
standings the fields combined have a
prize fund of $36,000 the top prize in
Group A is 6 grand the top prize in
Group B is 4 grand we play one classical
round of chess every day through
Thursday September 14 rounds begin at 1
p.m. here in st. Louis except for the
last day which begins earlier there's so
much left to play for in the glamour
division of the Fall Classic you'll see
the pairings for the next two rounds
because the next recap video that comes
to you will be a Sunday evening weekend
wrap-up edition well now here he is at
+1 Grandmaster Josh free del one of the
chess club's regular top grandmasters we
have here in all the US Championships
and everything else we have you playing
congratulations on your win today as
black against Alexander Shambhala take
us through the game and show us what
happened
yeah so I've had a lot of interesting
games with Alex over the years I would
say overall my score is not so great I
think I lost the first 5 games against
him when I was much younger but since
then I've gotten a couple wins but it's
it's not been so pleasant so I was very
happy to get the win today
he played c4 and I think he missed that
I could play Bishop g4 maybe he didn't
but I'm guessing he did because now his
bishop is threatened to be stranded if I
ever move my knight and I'm gonna be
able to play at h5 he played Queen e1
I expected a Knight f3 butts Queen e1 is
interesting so I think he was trying to
provoke me into playing this move I
don't know whether it's playable
computer might tell me I'm a [ __ ] for
enough planes but the idea is I thought
he would just start sacking stuff so B
should be too I can't give this check
but as pretty as this looks with 93
coming in he plays here and I actually
don't think I'm threatening anything
because for example if I start pitching
all mine pieces going a little fast but
the idea is basically that there's no
meat so it looks very pretty to do all
this with my Knights but I didn't find
anything it's very tempting especially
with the bishops out here I have c6
Queen b6 in some positions but I didn't
find anything and I was looking at this
one Queen h4 Knight takes a1 and I
thought he could either take or even
just take this Knight and again it's
kind of a weird position because his
bishops out of play I'm up in exchange
but it's also a little bit it was a
little bit scary after rook takes with
all the threats on my knight again I
thought objectively maybe this was the
way to go but I thought that I could
play Knight h5 and just end up up a pawn
which was a little simpler so he
surprises me again by taking and playing
maybe three takes I expected because
this bishop is quite bad but Knight b3
was a little unexpected so again I could
play a move like g5 but it's always a
little bit loose I thought this move was
much safer so my idea is that if he
tries queen of - I can play f5 we take
everything
and then I have a very important move g5
and after he retreats his rook I take
and all these end games are gonna be
terrible because I'm not that material
but he has all these split pawns I'm
gonna play c5 fix this guy he's gonna
stop for a long time and I figured he
would not do this he's not someone who
likes to defend tough end games he would
rather get active counter play so he
chose a very interesting move Queen a5
kind of a bolt from the blue but at the
same time it's not something that
worried me when he threw it done so I
played out 5 I thought that eventually
he might get made it here very easily if
he ever allows me to push up 3 it's
gonna be very nasty so he played rook f2
which is sort of a waiting move which
sounds weird but basically he's taking
advantage of the fact my pawn is pinned
and improving his pieces so if f3 his
rook is on a better Square and then
later he didn't want to move his bishop
because then it allows f3 immediately so
he wants to kind of keep me pinned while
improving his position so I thought I'd
maybe play rook e8 here which may have
been simpler but I chose c5 which I
thought made sense cutting off the Queen
and I also wanted to keep this Knight
from getting back in the game which I
thought was a good idea again maybe not
accurate but he took I took at the rook
Queen g6 and here I thought he was
almost busted I thought I was gonna play
f3 his position was on the verge of
collapse but he plays a very good move
92 which I missed and the idea is that
now his Knights coming to e4 and somehow
his pieces coordinate again maybe this
is just a win for me but I didn't think
it was so simple so I played f3 and here
I actually thought he was gonna play g3
which looks insane and again maybe it
loses but the problem is that if I take
this guy I can't quite get after this
pawn in time because there's Knights
coming to e4 f1 to defend and if I play
Knight f4 which looks like a monstrous
move he takes and I don't think I have
more than a perpetual after Bishop h3
Bishop g4 I was considering rook f7 with
a sneaky idea that if here I have a
discovery so he has to go back to a5 and
even with all his pieces out of play it
wouldn't surprise me if I'm winning here
but
did not see it so here I actually
thought this was a little difficult I
was considering playing rook back to f7
Queen c6 doubling rooks 94 and then
Bishop back because he can't really take
this pawn if Knight takes like grab on
g3 where he's gonna get mated if Queen
tix I take here it loses a piece if rook
takes I take and he loses a rook but I'm
also not totally sure I have a threat
because if I take the knight he
threatens to trade Queens so again I
wasn't really sure this was all that
amazing but he played this move which
surprised me and I thought that this was
quite good so I think he may have missed
something tactically here because he
played Bishop e3 which could not have
been his intention because if Brooke
takes you to I have Bishop h3 and he
can't take my queen cause of mates and
if he plays Queen takes d6 I think the
simplest way was to actually just trade
Queens put my Bishop on h3 and then rook
f8 comes and rook f1 which is deadly so
I think that he did not want to do this
so he played Bishop e3 and now it should
have been pretty easy to win but I let
him back in which has happened in a lot
of our games actually I've had a lot of
good positions but he's very resourceful
and I always have to be on my toes and I
thought I was but I missed something
here
rook p1 so my original intention and I
sort of stuck to it as usual is rook e8
and for example if rook b8 I think I can
even just play h6 and I mean the the
problem is there's always metaphor
tricks and Queen e6 is coming and I
think that he's just lost for example if
he tries to take this pawn I can even
just play King H someone take takes and
this is a very common pattern metaphor
and there's Queenie 192 and h3 to many
threats he shouldn't take this pawn but
again I think that it's pretty much over
I thought that this was actually quite
easy as well with my dear that after
appeared I'd take play King age 7 and
then I'm gonna just play Queen e6 and
he's gonna be in big trouble but he
plays this move and this was a real dash
of cold water for me because
the bishops attacked and it doesn't have
that many great squares and he takes
away a lot of my own squares so here I
thought that maybe I had already messed
it up lucky for me he didn't have tons
of time neither of us did but he he had
less and I think that helped me a little
bit
so I played Bishop b7 if I play Bishop
c6 the problem is that he plays queen c8
in my bishop has no score so I thought
I'd go here if Queen b8
I can play Queen back to f7 so he plays
Queen e7 I play Bishop c6 and then
Bishop f3 so the idea is that he doesn't
have any way to attack the Queen because
the square isn't available so he goes
back well my problem is I don't have
that many moves here but I did find an
idea which I thought was nice I played
d5 so if Bishop takes of course not a 4
if pawn takes my intention was Queen b6
threatening Queen b1 which is a very
nasty threat because he's gonna have
problems on the back rank please Bishop
c1 and here if Queen B 1 Queen III maybe
not so easy but I play an F for
threatening 92 which is a monster smooth
and if he takes then I play Queen B one
leading tomato and I thought that this
was a very nice line so he played Queen
takes which losses as well
after the game he mentioned he can throw
in this move which I may have overlooked
and then I thought I had a move here but
for some reason I may have just missed
something but I can go back but now he
can take and it's not as easy again I
feel like with the pawn on g2 it should
be quite good for block but at the same
time if I don't have anything forcing he
does have a lot of puns and the very
least this has become way more
complicated than it should have been for
me at the same time I still think that
maybe I have good chances to win here
but this would have been much tougher
and the game would probably still be
going instead he played Queen takes d5
so at first my intention was this
originally when I had planned this
but now threatening Queen f8 if Bishop
c1 the metaphor again but he has this
move and somehow Queen c1 comes and it's
not so easy but my other intention which
is what I ended up going with was an H
III
which is a forcing blow he played net h3
which losses as well but if pawn takes
Knight Queen h5 so first of all if
knight h3 King here I can
among other wins I can just queen
because there's mates if he plays any
the threat is just Queen age 1 followed
by checkmate if he moves the bishop
anywhere on this diagonal for example
say I don't know here I play Queen h1
takes takes check and then I do the very
boring thing in winners queen it's very
important as Queen's on c5 here because
there is no real checkmate otherwise I
don't think so that was the plan and
sorry if he goes the other way with the
bishop then I do actually get to give
checkmate I play here here of course he
can't ever go to t1 because the Queen e2
g5 Bishop g4 and mate what's Happ hoping
the game would end like this but instead
he played 9 at age 3 and now I thought
the simplest was to just take a piece
and again he can play on here but he
only has a pawn for the piece and he's
likely to get made it anyway so he just
resigned Queen g2 is coming next he
probably has to play this move but I can
kind of pick my choice here like Queen
g2 is very simple among others so he
decided just to resign so again I mean
overall I thought that I was on top most
of the game but it was definitely quite
a mess I played a couple clear errors to
give him maybe more chances than I
should have but overall pretty happy
with the win especially to be the player
who I've certainly had my share of
troubles with right and I really dug
that combination at the end with you
know pick your poison
when it comes to the Fall Classic what
does this tournament mean to you I mean
to be honest anytime I can play at the
club it's a nice thing because
conditions are really good here and it's
also quite a strong fields a beatable
field but a strong field
so and I don't get to play around
Robyn's very often so for me it's just a
great experience
well congratulations Josh thank you for
joining me
let's take a look at the standings after
round three in Group B Alejandra Ramirez
is still the man to beat in Group B
today Ramirez was naturalized as a US
citizen the process took a little bit
longer than usual so with the tournament
directors blessing and his opponents
blessing persona the game began three
hours late and it still proved to be a
fruitful one for Alejandro Ramirez here
are the pairings for the next two rounds
to take place on Saturday and Sunday
September 9 and 10
each rounds notable players will be
interviewed in this recap but remember
to follow the games live every day at
1:00 p.m. in st. Louis via Ches 24 and
us chess champs calm